It's time for hatred mail where a professional
voiceover artist does interpretive readings
of the hate mail that I get.
Here's a quick reminder about the foundation
of Patriot mail
because the government that is supposedly
totally Annette is the same government that
can pull off a conspiracy that will blow your
mind.
Okay.
Patriot Mayo written by patriots who hate
David Pacman because America and because freedom,
okay.
A new phrase coined this a week on hatred.
Mail, not mad Gha 2020 Miga 2020.
Take a look.
Has anyone ever seen a mouth on someone as
big as David Parkman?
His mouth is suspiciously big park man.
You're a real distorter of reality.
Your Biden is falling, but Harris's cutting
into Bernie Co foods.
Do you have no sense of perspective?
Mega 2020.
David Parkman is male version of Ellen.
Yeah, I don't.
I am sure that people in the audience are
going to come up with some, uh, funny explanations
for what Miga rather than Magda means.
I won't do your job for you.
I know you are very, very good at this.
I will simply remind you that you can send
a middle finger salute to the hatred, nuts,
uh, with the coupon code Patriot 40.
If you go to www.joinpacman.com select the
membership of your choice.
When you're asked for a coupon code type hatred,
40 you will save 40% and 1500 hatred.
Iots will cry every single time that that
coupon code is used.
Very exciting stuff.